So this is going to be a key concept for being able to develop and answer
two questions like that and it's the notion
of epsilon exhaustion. Which sounds kind of tiring.
>> I know I'm epsilon exhausted right now.
>> Yea, me too. So what we mean by
this is, well here's the definition. So, a version space.
Of, version space that is derived from a particular sample,
it's considered epsilon exhausted if and only if for all
the hypotheses that are in that version space they have low error. So
if we can do this then your algorithm going to work. Your algorithm
says at that point choose any of the hypotheses in your hypothesis set.
You are going to be fine, you are going to have low error.
>> Sure.
>> If you don't do this, your algorithm is
going to be in trouble because you are uniformly at
random choose one of the hypothesis and it has a
chance of being wrong. It could be a fairly high
chance if there is, say there is only two hypothesis
left in the version space, one has high error and one
has low error. We really have to make sure that
the only things left in the version space have low error
>> Okay, that makes sense, that makes sense.
>> Alright, so we're going to have to develop a little bit of
theory to figure out when that occurs but this is a really key concept.
>> Okay, so, I guess if was trying to put this
into English just to make certain I understand it, what you're saying
is, something is epsilon exhausted, a version
space is epsilon exhausted exactly in the
case when everything that you might possibly
choose has an error less than epsilon.
>> Sure.
>> Period. And so if there's anything in there that
has error greater than epsilon, then it's not epsilon exhausted.
>> Right. It's still epsilon energized.
>> Right. That makes a lot of sense, epsilon
energized. That's a pretty good name for a band. OK.
>> [LAUGH]